اعتذر رئيس الاتحاد الإسباني لكرة القدم
عن تقبيل أحد اللاعبين على
الشفاه بعد فوز الفريق بكأس العالم في
الفيديو الذي أظهر لويس روبياليس وهو يعانق المهاجمة
جيني هيرموسو ثم يضع
يديها على رأسها قبل تقبيلها،
وأين كنت مخطئًا بالتأكيد يجب أن
أعترف بذلك.
لأنه في لحظة أقصى قدر من العاطفة
والحماس دون أي
نوايا سيئة ودون أي سوء نية حسنًا،
حدث ما حدث
وبالطبع إذا كان هناك أشخاص
شعروا بالضرر بسبب هذا، يجب أن
أعتذر
بعد ذلك سُئلت هيرموسا عن ذلك من قبل
زملائها في الفريق وقالت  لم
يعجبها وسألها أحدهم
وقالت حسنًا ما الذي كان من المفترض أن أفعله ولكن
هذا الأمر قوبل
بعاصفة مطلقة من الانتقادات على مستوى العالم ولكن
بشكل خاص في إسبانيا
وصفه وزير المساواة بأنه شكل من أشكال
العنف الجنسي أحد السياسيين الإسبانيين
ودعا الحزب الرئيس إلى
التنحي